you've been in this field for over 20
years as you stated and I'm sure you've
seen a lot what is the hardest part of
this job the unpredictability and the
crisis driven work that we do every day
is a different day it also brings the
excitement to the job and keeps I think
me doing the job but the hard part is
never knowing when you walk in the door
or in the middle of the night if you're
gonna get a call about an egregious
incident
we're just faced with a number of major
challenges and we don't have enough
necessarily staff at times to manage all
of the families that we have to serve
what is the population here in out of
gaming around 180,000 80,000 how many
kids are in foster care right now 211
211 children in foster care
yeah it's increased that the one huge
stress stressor on our system in the
last four years as we've doubled the
number of children and out of home care
so we doubled the number of children in
foster care in the last four years right
yeah why is that kids are being put in
dangerous situations that we can't
control I would say 40% of the new kids
coming in are because of drugs and
alcohol and the the heroin and opiate
epidemic is huge
is it true though that say for instance
you see a bruise on a child's body you
have to go investigate that whereas
before you didn't
our reporting laws have increased we've
gone up over the last four years from
above proximately 2700 reports a year to
over 3400 reports in a year of abuse and
neglect so the people taking the calls
sometimes we're asking social workers
you need to take the phones because we
can't keep up with the reports do you
understand why when someone comes to
your office and says Melissa I just
can't do this anymore
I do I think I have a good idea we
survey staff we talk to our staff it's
it's the imbalance the work/life
imbalance and it's unpredictable have
you ever lost the child oh yes when I
did the work for 16 years I had numerous
children die or be brutally assaulted we
still see that happening kids are really
hurt and harmed in ways on him sometimes
I say we talk internally like
unimaginable ways how do you deal with
that how do you keep coming to work and
showing up day after day and then have
the energy to train young people that
are coming in and convinced them they
can do it it's got its ups and downs and
challenges but this is real work what we
do has a positive impact on families and
you know not everybody can say that
about their job when you hear these
stories of these innocent lives being
lost at the hands of parents or
stepparents and then you hear that
second piece of Child Protective
Services visited this family six months
ago three months ago what's your
reaction and do you go another black eye
on our agency we don't have a magic ball
so some things terrible things happen in
a split second so a child can a parent
can do something or a boyfriend or
caregiver can do something in a split
second how would we ever be able to
predict that you know we don't want to
raise children we want families to be
supported and thriving in our community
that gives the that's why I'm doing this
as long as I am that's the hope and
optimism of doing this job but I always
say it's hard to work so this starts
part
this is the difference in what we do is
you know it's not only hard at work it's
hard to work when kids were UniFi when
they get to go home from foster care we
celebrate that that because a family
gets to heal and be together